to me a good tattoo is a clean outline
smooth shading
if it's color solid color
and originality
makes a good tattoo changes
if you have lighter skin you can almost
do a tattoo just as you would a painting
but if you have darker skin then you
need to simplify it so it can be seen
when it come to tattooing i'm just a
vessel of that creativity
i'm just sitting back watching my hand
move
i'm not thinking about it
i know it ain't me no more
it's creations god it's another place
and i don't care what the complexion of
a person is i'm going to make them
something beautiful
[Music]
who is maya bailey
i would probably say artist
community builder team builder
i would describe peter street station
first is an art and design community
center down here in atlanta
we got tattoo artists painters our
writers our musicians our singers
underwear roof and we feed off each
other
and my whole goal is to create new
styles of art and let these younger
artists shine
train them
make sure i got full attention on their
resources
my whole goal is to see them go as far
as they want to go
right now i shall lead you into the
humble abode
when people come in and they get in a
tattoo we give them a tour to build it
maya has his private art collection
hanging up here
my whole goal is to make sure that
people come here feel welcomed so this
is maya station this is where you will
be getting tattooed i want them to be
excited too because when they excited it
made me excited
when the client get here i'm not gonna
be here
but i got apprentices
and
what they're supposed to do is get this
client comfortable nice to meet you
all right so what are you getting today
i don't know you don't know no
there are a couple of elements i would
like to include like i would like a home
that's very important to me like it's a
very big part of who and what i am
before i get to work you know the first
thing i do i make sure i got some alone
time take a long walk
i kind of take as much time i can on my
dogs enjoy that watch them play around
i really truly don't know exactly what
i'm going to do till i get there
good to meet you you as well
[Music]
tell me a concept today so um
i'm a tattoo artist yeah right um and
you are my inspiration for being one oh
thank you
damn i would love anything in your style
i like bright colors and i love cartoons
if you think like your favorite cartoon
the simpsons yes
when i meet the person for the first
time i kind of just let them do they
talking you know what i'm saying like
when they explain it to me face to face
i can feel it i like abstract work i
like masks i have a lot of people in
healthcare in my family so i wanted to
kind of just give a little tribute to
the healers in my family okay okay once
they started reading out the story it's
like okay either gonna be family based
uh
trauma or overcoming
or
spiritual growth
when i was telling my wife about coming
here and like how this was i don't want
to say it's a religious experience for
me because but it is you know what i
mean and so i just want that pouring
into this
before we start step one my apprentices
they prep the whole area
they set up my inks in certain orders
the darks delights
then they're gonna shade the arm
and just make sure that the skin is
completely smooth without hair you want
a needle jacket up in a piece of hair
or you run over a piece of hair you mess
up your line or get tangled and it pulls
the hair out that hurts you know what
i'm saying
the next step is the freehand work
i get my red marker first
red is just sketch so you'll see me
sketch with the red
get a nice rhythm going
then i take a black marker and then i do
the black line it's the actual line that
the client is going to see
that's when i'm showing the actual
designs my guidelines the black lines
when i use straight lines that means i'm
thinking logic
thinking thoughts
but anytime you see curves and movement
in it it represents love or emotion
after i finished doing the black ink
then that's when you know i'm kind of
finished the design let the client stand
up look in the mirror
usually they like it
i just wait for that expression and once
i get that expression on a face
then i know
that uh it's gonna be a good session
increasingly the institutional art world
is honing in on tattooing as being a
kind of art
and we've seen people that have
completed their art degrees moving to
tattooing
i'm david lane i'm an assistant
professor of criminal justice sciences
at illinois state university
part of what i study is crime and
deviance and the other part is culture
and art
the crime and deviance pays the bills
but i also get to do the art part when i
study tattooing
the oldest human bodies ever recovered
have tattoos on them
meaning that we know it's at least a 5
000 year old practice
there's not a single tribal society in
the world in which the indigenous people
don't practice tattooing
we can go to new zealand historically in
the maori tribes often their face
documented a lot of things like whether
people were on their first or second
marriage uh what kind of labor they
carried out their family lineage all
sorts of things could be read off the
face here in what's now the united
states we have documentation that alaska
natives tattooed people in the southwest
tattooed themselves even in tennessee
we've found two thousand year old tattoo
needles
and then ultimately if we think about
our contemporary context
tattooing it's more popular and
accessible than it ever has been before
[Music]
there were a few sort of pop culture
things that all sort of coincided over a
number of decades
[Music]
we had pop stars getting tattooed and by
the 1980s and definitely by the 90s
you're starting to see athletes whether
it's football or nba they're visibly
tattooed
by the time we get into the mid-2000s we
sort of have the birth of social media
and that allows people to take images of
their own tattoos or take images of
tattoos they've produced and spread it
to new audiences easier
when i first started doing this research
and this is over a decade ago
jackie gresham was one of the first
names that ever came up
the conversation around jackie i it can
be summed up in a couple words
original
and and groundbreaking
my name is jackie gresham and i've been
in new orleans for 45 years tattooing
i'm the first black woman to tattoo
this shop
back in the 70s and 80s we had bike
clubs come in here every sunday they
would come in here
and back then that was pretty much your
clientele
jackie was doing imagery that was an
aesthetic challenge to what some white
tattooers had considered the sort of
essence of tattooing so she sort of
broken ground in that sense
today
tattoos the different types are endless
if you can see it we can do it as a
tattoo
miss jackie the world should know who
she is in my opinion
she's special
imagine what she had to deal with i came
up in the 90s and it was super racist so
i couldn't imagine anything she had to
go through
i think it makes it harder that i was a
black person i think also
women in the industry have a hard time
as well
when i wanted to buy this building i had
15 000 down that's 25
but the people would not sell it to me
so that is a prime example
but with our society today i don't think
you're going to have a problem
they have a lot of super
black artists that are incredible tattoo
artists and i think that people will
come to you and appreciate the good
artwork that you're doing
[Music]
once this tattoo is laid out and i'm
doing freehand
i start everything from the right hand
corner so i don't swipe off my stencil
so you'll see me go do a quick outline
around the whole entire thing because if
i don't it's gonna be wiping off the
person's gonna be sweating all this
stuff so i'm doing a quick outline
around the whole entire thing so i don't
lose it
then i come in different line weights
doubling up lines to make it fatter
thicker
and then i fill up my solid black areas
next to build out contrast
when i'm doing color i always say what's
the darkest part of my tattoo
so i might do say hey i'm gonna use
turquoise and i'm gonna do another color
next to turquoise that's not related to
turquoise so it can make the darker
turquoise color look even brighter
with the blackened grays there's more
thinking with black and gray a little
bit because with black and gray you
really got to make an image pop out
using only a few tones
with a color tattoo the black and gray
under the tattoo is just your contrast
and you don't color right on top of that
like an overlay
so those pores are open and they're
healing at the same time so you got to
hurry up doing this color
it's getting swollen and sore right now
i got to knock this out before this
person tap out on me
i was probably always an artist growing
up
my mom was like i wouldn't even walk
and i could draw
and then as a child
i was going to the library and one of
the books i picked up was created by don
ed hardy
and i read it and i thought about my
father having a tattoo
so
my mind clicked i'm like man you know
i think i'm something i'm interested in
doing
you know and in my time wasn't black
tattoo artists at all it was probably
like at this time probably four in the
world
and
it was no black tattoo artist north
carolina period i was the first one
so i ended up going to a tattoo shot
called liquid dragon
took me in man and just showed me some
ropes
but i was messing around in the streets
and kind of blew that just trying to
find myself as a young man getting in a
whole bunch of trouble like most young
men do
and i blew my opportunity but it kind of
opened up a door for me to move out of
my hometown and move to atlanta
and i ended up opening up my first
tattoo shop
it made some good money so it gave me
that freedom to be able to paint and
explore art more in the gallery scene
[Music]
i'm a painter that's what i really do
for a living
painting i feel like that's my right
there you getting to see pure me
i'm not worried about nothing
i'm not worried about if it's pretty or
not
because tattooed i gotta make it pretty
i gotta make it beautiful
but painting you don't have to make it
beautiful
you're feeling ugly then you can express
that
we are done
once you finish the color order black
and gray whatever tattoo you're doing
the next step is really
they gonna see it
they look at it from that angle but then
you want to look in the mirror so they
can see the reflection how it will be
naturally on their arm
the second reaction is very important
you know what i'm saying because you
definitely it's over you want them for
relief and you want them to be happy at
the same time you like it i love it
thank you so much thank you
that's the part i like the most when i
client looking at mirror and see that
permanent thing i put on there
yeah man it's a big it's a big
responsibility
then we bring them back
i take my photos my pictures for my
social media
and then i wrap them up
i use like a saran wrap basic stuff just
to catch the blood and it'll mess up the
clothes
thank you so much
[Music]
when it's done
i'm more thankful than anything because
i'm like damn i just made fifteen
hundred dollars and this money is going
to go back to the apprentices hosting
them it's going back to their careers
getting them a place to work and it's
just a good cycle that's what i'm trying
to do
if you want there to be a vibrant tattoo
culture you ought to go be a member of
it
so go meet tattooers and get to know
them and figure out if you like them
because you're going to have a moment
that's going to be with you for a while
you might as well have a good time while
doing it
when it comes to tattooing i'd be
feeling more like a healer or sherman
even though you really don't need a
tattoo
but it made me feel like they needed
that and it's really for them it's
really for me
you